notre histoire commence le samedi 27
août dernier lorsque mathias pogba frère
de paul pogba parce que ces idéaux sur
les réseaux sociaux
je pense que ce que j'ai à dire est ce
que l'intéressé beaucoup de monde pousse
à risques des explosifs
une vidéo à charge contre son frère qui
publiant plusieurs langues
dès le lendemain les avocats de paul
pogba réagissent à cette vidéo
mystérieuse dans un communiqué les
déclarations récentes de mathias pogba
sur les réseaux sociaux ne sont
malheureusement pas une surprise elle
s'ajoute à des menaces et des tentatives
d'extorsion en bande organisée contre
paul pogba dans la nuit du 28 au 29 août
matthias fawer réitère ses propos dans
un message sur twitter
paul tu voulais vraiment me faire taire
quitte à mentir et m'envoyer en prison
ma version des faits arrive et
contrairement à toi j'ai de quoi prouver
mes dires et et mensonges manipuler les
gens c'est pas bien ce matin cet affront
entre les deux frères fait l'effet d'une
bombe dans la planète football et est à
la une des journaux du monde entier
ce soir vous saurez tout sur cette
affaire
merci philippe carayon être avec nos
chandails sportif qui n'a plus est dans
un instant vous fera une révélation sur
cette affaire merci d'être là pour ceux
qui n'ont pas vu on a la vidéo choc de
mathias pogba pour ceux qui n'ont pas
encore regardé c'est parti
si je fais cette vidéo aujourd'hui mais
non cette démarche c'est que j'estime
que le milieu français italien espagnol
anglais mais de savoir une chose afin de
décider en toute connaissance de cause
s'il avait une maman de l'admiration le
respect et l'amour de la république je
pense que ce que j'ai à dire risque
d'intéresser beaucoup de monde
d'ailleurs je vous parlais aussi des
choses très importantes à propos des
clés rénova p la star du football
et il y aura des éléments et de l'ong au
témoignage pour confirmer les propos
tout ça puisque explosif
alors ça exclut d'affaires mondial alors
philippe qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est
quoi cette affaire pour les
téléspectateurs qui n'ont pas suivi qui
se passe mais déjà c'est la stupéfaction
la plus totale et l effroi général dans
le monde du foot dans le monde des
médias acte 2 1 avant-hier cette vidéo
absolument tonitruante il mouille son
frère ainsi que kilian mba p hier acte 2
communiqué des avocats de la famille ou
plutôt de paul pogba soutenu par la
maman des deux frères dix ans par écrit
qu'il y a un lien entre l'attitude de
mathias et une tentative d'extorsion
d'argent subie par paul pogba dans la
foulée deux médias la fpf france info
nous donne des précisions jean-paul
conditionnelle il y aurait une enquête
ouverte depuis début août pour tentative
ou carrément extorsion d'argent sur paul
pogba paul pogba aux policiers auraient
déclaré que des bus à turin où il
revenait à la juventus à l'entraînement
il aurait été victime d'une intimidation
par deux hommes cagoulés et armés de
fusils d'assaut visant à lui extorquer
13 millions d'euros alors je vous dire
nous on a eu peu mathias pogba par
téléphone les équipes l'ont eue et
mathias pogba nous a dit vraiment que
tout ce qui était dit actuellement et n
importe quoi que la sphère partait dans
tous les sens sachez le que tout ce que
vous entendez il faut s'en méfier
ardemment et que voilà cette affaire on
aura la vérité très prochainement et je
vous dire comment je vais vous dire
pourquoi mais sachez qu'en tout cas
mathias dit vraiment que tout cela est
un tissu de mensonges et que plus les
jours avancent plus les heures avancent
et plus il y à des mensonges qui sont
proférées à son égard par les différents
médias par les voilà la famille etc donc
il veut rétablir la vérité assez vite et
il va le faire d'ailleurs très très
rapidement je vous dirai comment dans un
instant juste
qu'est ce que qu'est-ce qu'on a parlé d'
affaire de sorcellerie c'est quoi cette
affaire sur alors fait ça ils aiment
maps et on a déjà entendu ça aussi c'est
quoi ces j'ai lu ça ça c'est le volet m
bape et de la faire on apprend hier que
ce que s'apprêtaient où ça prêterait a
révélé mathias c'est un maraboutage de
kylie ann m bape est commandité par paul
pogba via un marabout pour lui jeter un
sort hier soir mathias pogba dans sa
série de tweets convient de voir dans
votre sujet a confirmé ce maraboutage il
est ce que tu peux nous faire un résumé
pour les téléspectateurs qui nous
rejoignent il ya quelques mois paul
pogba qui jouait à manchester united
décide de faire le ménage dans son
entourage il s'aperçoit très grand
joueur très grand joueur international
français champion du monde un des plus
grands joueurs français il vit à
manchester avec famille amis il
s'aperçoit que un proche lui a dérobé
deux cent mille euros sur sa carte bleue
il dit là il a beaucoup d'argent mais il
dit là je peux plus je vire tout le
monde il vient en mars un rassemblement
de l'équipe de france et puis il va dans
sa famille à lagny sur marne et là il
est happé par des gens qui l'emmène à
paris dans un appartement qu'il enlève
en calcul c'est ce qu'ils nient bah oui
c'est ce qu'ils les pluies sont en tout
cas s qui dit après la pause opposition
sans contact avec mathias pogba ça chez
eux depuis 48 heures mercredi
le dossier passe ici notre cheminement
et c'est sûr je peux vous le dire
mathias pogba viendra normalement
s'exprimer dans tpm paix dans les
prochains jours pour nous raconter sa
version es qui pour nous raconter toute
l'histoire sachez le oui alors c'est
quoi cette histoire de maraboutage alors
le maraboutage on sait très bien que 1
beaucoup de joueurs de football
utilisent des marabouts d'ailleurs paul
pogba reconnaît lui même que pour sa
protection il fait appel à marabo pour
se protéger et il n'est pas le seul mais
là où ça devient explosif et où ça
touche l'équipe de france juste avant la
coupe du monde c'est qu'il aurait
marabouté qu'il y a même map et les deux
hommes ne s'entendent pas très bien il
sombra amis voilà il l'aurait marabouté
pour que kylie ann mbacké et des
problèmes joue moins bien et il y aurait
ça se sait nos infos de l'équipe il y
aurait une vidéo qui prouverait
réellement que paul pogba a fait appel à
un marabout pour que kilian mba paix
joue moins bien au foot donc là ça fait
sensation et c'est toute l'équipe de
france qui maintenant doit se
réconcilier alors sachez qu'ils aient
une info qui vient de wimbée paul pogba
déclaré avoir versé des dizaines de
milliers d'euros à d'anciennes
fréquentation qu'est ce que c'était il
lui demander quoi de la protection c'est
quoi cette protection au fossé c'est du
racket tout simplement ça c'est l'info
la dernière info du jour c'est
malheureusement le lot de beaucoup de
footballeurs et de l'espoir que les deux
chanteurs sauf que c'est ma soeur sauf
que sera n'éclate pas et d'anima sur la
place nantes va pas comme comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui non mais c'est vrai
alors oui vous avez des infos non j'ai
pas moi j'ai repensé à cette histoire
hier soir ce que j'ai regardé le match
psg monaco et même si je crois pas
tellement au maraboutage mes preuves
preuve est que hier soir elle m'appelle
pour une fois il n'a jamais marqué la
série sur la barre j'ai pensé qu'à ça
josy ouais ouais bah si je me suis la
chance la chance la quitter
oui qu'est ce que reproche mathias à son
frère on n'a toujours pas compris oui
c'est vrai la raison est question c'est
quoi eh ben on attend toujours si ce
risque qu'elle recevait ce reproche à
son frère d'avoir fait office de garde
du corps pendant des années des années
depuis près de 10 ans auprès de son
frère paul et nous nous avoir été pays
rétribuer financièrement pour ce sera
jean ils ont lancé une fondation en
semblant marx et il est venu d'ailleurs
revenu exactement où va bien fondation à
but humanitaire ces sympathiques
formidables et puis d'un coup tout
éclate et comme c'est au moment où il ya
le transfert à la juventus de turin au
moment où l'agent historique de paul
pogba est décédé on se dit que c'est
peut-être une histoire d'argent qui fait
imploser la famille et vous avez raison
cyril la version de mathias est très
très attendu mais alors il va nous dire
ce qu'ils reprochent à paul pogba et ce
sera aux experts dans quelques jours
dans quelques heures dans tpm pays vous
serez bien sûr au courant très très vite
on